ora sì io mi occupo di religioni
pur non avendo avuto una formazione
confessionale e neppure di tipo
religioso
e però appunto me ne occupo soprattutto
così per un interesse personale ma
soprattutto perché ci ho lavorato e ci
sto lavorando da molto tempo in questa
trasmissione radiofonica
naturalmente è sempre un po imbarazzante
e l'ho notato anche in questi giorni
anche ieri sera e poi stamattina parlare
di religioni a un contesto vasto e
composito perché sicuramente tra voi c'è
chi ha una fede certa che io sicuramente
non vorrei ferire c'è chi invece ritiene
le religioni una sopravvivenza del
passato con delle buone ragioni che non
vorrei contraddire e c'è chi ritiene che
le religioni sono così un orpello
inutile inutile interessarsene sono
capaci di portare soltanto violenza e
distruzione
e anche questo ha un suo senso e poi
parlare di religioni è complicato perché
dentro questa categoria facciamo
confluire una serie sterminata di storie
e di esperienze ci sono le religioni che
hanno un dio e quelle senza dio
le religioni politi politeiste e quelle
monoteiste ci sono religioni scomparse e
nuove fedi religioni intese come fatto
privato
e invece religioni intese come elemento
identitario e oltre a ciò ogni religione
si è articolata in uno spazio infinito
di scuole sette chiese derivazioni
eccetera eccetera
e poi ancora quando diciamo religioni di
che cosa parliamo parliamo dei leader e
come si dice delle grandi religioni
oppure parliamo
non lo so di un di un prete di strada o
di un monaco ritirato nel suo eremo o
invece di un cardinale di cui o
fondamentalista fanatico sono tante le
cose che si possono dire allora per
questo io vorrei proporvi due percorsi
questa sera perché ci si potrebbe
smarrire come di fronte a ogni altra
esperienza dell'umano pensate e
all'esperienza scientifica la
letteratura la società alla storia
ecco però appunto il fatto religioso
appartiene al tempo dell'umano e dunque
noi possiamo rinvenire qualche traccia
almeno delle antiche sapienze che possa
avere un senso forse per l'umanità tutta
intera
allora il primo passo di questo percorso
parte da un testo antichissimo i veda
una raccolta di testi dei popoli ari e
stanziati nell'india settentrionale
composto tra il 1100 strà era il 1500
volte nostra era e il mille l'anno mille
che compendiano appunto vari saperi
allora sentitevi voglio leggere soltanto
un frammento in principio non vi era
essere né non essere non vi era l'aria
n'è ancora il cielo al di là che cosa lo
avvolgeva dove chi proteggeva c'era
l'acqua insondabile profonda in quel
momento non vi era né la morte
nell'immortalità non vi era segno della
notte e del giorno da dove questa
creazione sia sorta se gliela fondato
oppure no
colui che la sorveglia nel più alto dei
cieli lui solo lo sa o forse non lo sa
ecco allora
vedete così comincia il pensare
dell'uomo con l'interrogazione con lo
stupore il desiderio di sapere ma anche
la coscienza di non sapere qualcosa di
grandioso in questo interrogare e in
questo dubitare ciò che ha mosso ha dato
origine alle grandi tradizioni religiose
e quello che ha mosso e dato origine a
tutto il sapere dell'umanità fino ad
arrivare alla ricerca spaziale o alla al
web al wireless e così via
la scienza la raffigurazione artistica
la scrittura la misurazione della
creatura umana dentro l'universo
allora io credo che dovremmo tener care
le domande delle antiche sapienze perché
sono le stesse che animano ogni indagine
dell'essere umano anche nel nostro tempo
dovremo tener caro quel loro affacciarsi
sulla scena del mondo
avete sentito lo stupore di essere vivi
lo stupore di essere qualcosa in questa
vita a queste domande allora vanno
custodite ma non fossilizzate come
spesso le istituzioni religiose hanno
fatto non codificate ma spalancate
tenendo aperta la molteplicità delle
risposte
scegliendo certamente ciascuno di noi
sceglierà una strada perché non può
percorrere tutte però sapendo che invece
ce ne sono tante altre
allora sono così si può far circolare
aria vento respiro dentro quelle domande
senza soffocarle nel chiuso asfittico le
sacrestie di sette di estremismi e
causando intelligenza usando critica
mettendo in crisi ogni volta le idee
troppo computer aprendo orizzonti nuovi
e nuove libertà pensate come sarebbe
umiliante come
molto umiliante nella storia degli
esseri umani ridurre la propria libertà
ridurre anche il libero osare del
pensiero in nome di un credo di una
convinzione di un principio questo è
accaduto molto spesso la storia delle
religioni ma il fondamento delle fedi
sta in altro sta nell'aperto l'altro
percorso che vi voglio proporre muove
invece da una diversa un diverso input
una diversa spinta che ha contribuito a
creare forgiare plasmare far nascere le
religioni quello di alleviare le
sofferenze degli esseri umani
quello di dare un senso al dolore di
estinguerlo dove sia possibile quello di
contenere le forze distruttive che ci
abitano quello di provare a fare
comunità a fare città a fare società a
costruire convivenza è vero che nella
storia le tradizioni religiose hanno
provocato guerre sostenuto violenze
incoraggiato suprusi commentato
distrutti istruzioni ma questo è
accaduto e accade sempre continua a
cadere quando si smette di interrogare
quando si crede di possedere la verità
invece di continuare a cercarla quando
invece di un dio inafferrabile
inconoscibile costruiamo con le nostre
mani una serie infinita di idoli una
serie infinita di vitelli d'oro ed è
bene ricordare che idolatra non soltanto
che si costruisce una falsa immagine di
dio ma che le nostre vite sono abitate
da idoli pensiamo al litro del denaro
del possesso
l'idolo che ciascuno di noi ea se stesso
signore liberami da me stesso dice una
poesia di fernando pessoa allora come
fare in modo che dio non sia un idolo il
volto di dio non si può vedere questo è
scritto nei libri della torah e dunque
non si può vedere vuol dire che non ci
ha dato immaginario
non c'è dato farne feticci e statuette
presumere di conoscerlo illudersi che
sia dalla nostra parte
questo guardate che è un comandamento è
il secondo dei comandamenti dopo io sono
il signore che vuol dire che esiste un
dio se esiste naturalmente ma unico per
tutta l'umanità
e poi vi è il terzo comandamento non
pronunciare falsamente il suo nome e
cioè a rigore siccome nulla di vero uomo
può sapere su dio
meglio non proferire mai il suo nome è
difatti il nome di dio e inconoscibile è
contenuto in quattro lettere
impronunciabili e pensate che anche
nella tradizione islamica
ci sono 99 i nomi di dio ma non sono dei
sostantivi sono degli aggettivi cioè
degli attributi e poi c'è un centesimo
nome che nessuno conosce perché lo
conosce solo dio
ecco capiamo bene che cosa significa
questo c'è un dio il cui volto non si
può vedere il cui nome non si preoccupò
pronunciare è un dio dai larghi con fini
è un dio che abita nelle profondità dei
cuori umani ma anche negli abissi degli
universi e tuttavia di quel dio o di
quel qualcosa a cui noi abbiamo dato ed
abbiamo il nome di dio vi è traccia
nella ricerca degli esseri umani di una
traccia scritta nella storia dell'uomo
nelle strategie per costruire una città
degli uomini dove i conflitti possano
essere mediati elaborati dove le libertà
degli uni entrino in dialettica con le
libertà degli altri
dove sia possibile una vita di umanità e
non di bestialità un altro testo
un'altra affermazione dio nessuno lo ha
mai visto questo è scritto nel prologo
del vangelo di giovanni
e in una delle lettere di giovanni si
dice ancora nessuno ha mai visto dio e
si aggiunge subito dopo
se ci amiamo gli uni gli altri dio
rimane in noi e l'amore di lui è
perfetto in noi però cerchiamo di capire
anche qui questa implicazione nessuno ha
mai visto dio punto se ci amiamo gli uni
latri dio rimane in noi e l'amore di lui
è perfetto in noi allora ciò che conta
non è immaginarsi dio che cosa sia dio
ma quella parola che viene definita con
amore l'amore che sappiamo scambiarci
l'amore che sappiamo costruire l'amore
che sappiamo realizzare però certamente
l'amore che parola imbarazzante che
parola abusata di vita qualche volta a
me personalmente viene la nausea sentir
parlare di questo amore una parola
astratta più pronunciata che non
realizzata nei fatti e poi anche non ci
facciamo illusioni sulla creatura umana
sappiamo di cosa siamo fatti
sappiamo che siamo un impasto di di di
tensioni di amore di odio mi piace
ricordare le parole di pascal quale
chimera e l'uomo
quale novità quale mostro quale caos
quale soggetto di contraddizione quale
prodigio giudice di tutte le cose
e stupido verme della terra depositario
della verità e cloaca di incertezze di
errore gloria e rifiuto dell'universo ma
l'essere umano è anche capace di
quell'amore di quell attenzione
all'altro di quella cura di quella
responsabilità per l'altro che lo rende
umano ed è questo che conta è questo che
conta anche per il dio della bibbia che
dice per bocca dei suoi profeti io
detesto le vostre feste non gradisco le
vostre riunioni mio no
anche se voi mi offrite olocausti a me
non interessano
non voglio le vostre vittime grasse
lontano da me il frastuono dei vostri
canti il suono delle vostre arpe
piuttosto scorra come acqua il diritto e
la giustizia come un torrente perenne la
rettitudine la giustizia non nuocere
il costruire cose buone e della vita
umana che ci parlano le scritture
per questo credo vanno lette studiate
comprese interpretate in un commento che
non ha mai fine perché cresce con noi
con ciascun essere umano che le ha costi
così come noi cresciamo con la
frequentazione di quelle parole e di
quella continua interpretazione e ci
accorgeremo allora come vi sia un filo
che unisce le scritture le tradizioni di
tutti i tempi e di tutti i luoghi ed è
appunto l'attenzione all'umano
come avete presente nei vangeli
sinottici quando qualcuno chiede a gesù
qual è il comandamento più grande lui
mette insieme
questo è il racconto diciamo due
proposizioni nell'antico testamento ama
il dio unico e ama il prossimo tuo
perché egli è te stesso e dice questo è
un unico comandamento allora questo
significa che se si ama dio se qualcuno
dice di amare dio non è vero se non ama
anche il suo prossimo e se hanno il suo
prossimo
questo è sufficiente per amare anche dio
e se noi allarghiamo lo sguardo al di
fuori delle scritture giudaico cristiane
vediamo che in tutte ma davvero in tutte
troviamo in tutte le sapienze non solo
le scritture troviamo affermazioni
analoghe nei grandi poemi indiani e nei
discorsi del budda nei pensieri del
confidi confucio nelle massime del tau
nel giainismo nello zoo astri smo nei
detti del profeta mohammad nella
sapienza latina fino ad arrivare alla
dichiarazione
uno dei diritti dell'uomo tutti gli
uomini dotati ragioni di coscienza
devono assumere responsabilità in
spirito di solidarietà nei confronti di
ciascuno e di tutti famiglie comunità
nazioni religioni ciò che tu non vuoi
che ti venga fatto non farlo a nessun
altro questo in definitiva il programma
di ogni religione e non mi sembra un
piccolo programma non mi sembra
trascurabile per questo credo che valga
la pena oggi interrogare un cuore
tracciati delle fedi non credo che ci
dobbiamo sbarazzare delle religioni
credo che ci dobbiamo sbarazzare di una
lettura ottusa delle religioni di un
ascolto opaco con orecchio ostruito
d'ortica come dice la poetessa nelly
sachs
ecco credo che ciascuno dovrebbe
sentirsi responsabile dal patrimonio di
tradizione che ha ricevuto in eredità
anzi ognuno di noi dovrebbe farsi
tradizione e assumersi il rischio di una
interpretazione dei testi antichi che
sia all'altezza del nostro presente con
rispetto ma senza sudditanza con
cognizione ma anche con audacia
rigenerare rianimare le parole antiche
rileggerle alla luce del presente e
voglio chiudermi leggendoli un versetto
date utero nord del deuteronomio che
dice questo comando che oggi ti do non è
troppo alto per te né troppo lontano da
te non è nel cielo così che tu possa
dire come faccio a raggiungerlo non è al
di là del mare così che tu possa dire ma
chi me lo potrà mai portare vicino anzi
questa parola è molto vicina a te e
nella tua bocca e nel tuo cuore perché
tu la metta in pratica vedi io oggi
pongo di fronte a te la vita e il bene
la morte e il male la benedizione e la
maledizione
scegli dunque
perché tu possa vivere tu e la tua
discendenza
ecco si tratta anche per noi credo di
scegliere la vita o almeno di provarci
spero di avere spostato almeno un poco
le vostre convinzioni grazie